[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys ready make the next move make
that move this make moves let's make
that move make that move with
Squarespace what you're trying to do
would you try to be a rapper a singer
you're trying to sell stuff on the
internet what are you trying to do
because whatever it is
Squarespace got your back wherever your
next move is they're gonna throw you 10%
off if you give them the promo code
Hannibal at squarespace.com they got
award-winning templates it's real easy
to set up it's all smooth it's oh good
you know gotta pay hundreds of dollars
to get that website popping you just
gotta go to Squarespace and that's where
you make your next move it's don't man
get a unique domain you got to install
nothing you just go on the site and you
just start clicking and you start
[ __ ] around and next thing you know
everybody thinks you're a goddamn
professional and you need that in your
life so go to squarespace.com and enter
the promo code Hannibal and get that ten
percent off and go ahead and make moves
I believe in you
[Music]
what's up you listening to another
episode handsome ramble bears co-host
Tony trim what up special guests creator
and composer of handsome rambling intro
music Flying Lotus no problem
thank you for coming through excited to
talk to you you're fresh off your film
your directorial debut yeah kuso
Sundance yeah I did a voice in it how'd
it go first off you did great I was uh
I'm so happy with the way that came out
it
thanks man I was really really happy
with it and it all you know I had so
much stuff to work with that it was like
it was just sad that I couldn't use
everything you know I really enjoyed
enjoyed that process yeah it was uh it
was hard making movies [ __ ] up I I
definitely underestimated the entire
process I knew it's gonna be difficult
but yeah yeah you know well I have way
more help and I thought it wouldn't cost
nearly as much as it did but uh yeah so
you financed out of pocket I did yeah
yeah yeah I don't recommend it but I did
that well the benefit when you spend
your own money you ain't got answers
nobody else that's true what you
something you definitely didn't have to
yeah no one no one would have made them
no yeah it's fine you went all in on
that one I did
I didn't watch the whole thing because
it is it is out of watts
yeah you sent me that sexy the one
strangulation oh right yeah first thing
yeah and now was very I was like what is
happening yeah how do you even think of
this thing what what happened [ __ ] man I
don't know I just uh I just I like
making stuff that you know we all joke
about you know things that we talk about
and it's always like oh that wouldn't
that be crazy you know you make like
something like real vulgar disgusting
joke and was they won't
Wow let's make that yeah that's that was
kind of attitude it's like you know I
wanted it to be things that you know
confront things that I'm afraid of and
to confront things that freaked me out
because I feel like I have a pretty high
threshold you know but yeah so I wanted
I wanted to try try some of that stuff
yeah that's cool that is it is just the
visuals and just the the look of it and
it's very some specific weird [ __ ] what
was the writing process yeah I've heard
other interviews where you wanted to
make film for a while what got you to
this point was I'm making this there was
it a certain scene we said that's a
scene and then I'm gonna keep making
[ __ ] off of this I did what was yeah I
was a I started messing with Photoshop a
lot and it was like early in the process
of like this whole thing started as an
animation and I was using Photoshop and
make characters and stuff and you know I
was getting on these boils and getting
all this weird faces yes starting advice
faces and stuff and I was like wow there
should be a movie with these characters
in it it's like I want to make this for
real you know and it just it kind of
blossomed from that idea and I started
in the world and you know saying what if
there's this thing going whatever and uh
and it just kind of evolved from that
and and yeah just the scenarios I don't
really even know how they come to me man
I just I just think about it like as a
joke you know like wouldn't that be
funny if yeah you know and then you you
build the world around this idea and you
know things start happening phone calls
get made and whatever started seeing
puppets come to life how integrated was
your music with that was it just like
its own thing or was it like creative it
was a bit together it was a bit of both
you know I actually tried to I wanted to
have the experience of making the music
after the film instead of being like
yeah it round you know you wanted to
soundtrack it you said yeah yeah so I
left room for for both things you know I
wanted it to go in with some music and
then you know do something in the end of
it - yeah I never like directed your own
music videos or anything like that not
my own personally I've done some music
videos but you know that it's never been
as you know it's this is very much my
baby yeah you know this thing is like
you know the result of like a lot of you
know my own personal stuff you know
music videos it's like it's a bit
different and getting more abstracted by
other people's ideas yeah yeah
sensibilities and whatnot this is life
yeah so what was the timeline from first
shot to Sundance how much time I started
working on it every day starting from
October 2015
yeah so it took me all that time yeah
pretty much tell him I'm still working
on it
yeah you know right now so what was the
the premiere like man the premiere was
amazing yeah it was amazing it was it
went down it went down so well I was
like I was really I was nervous as [ __ ]
I had a I was just tripping everything
that I was just I was like lost in my
head and
when the brain-fever logo popped on and
I everybody started shouting all right
we cool yeah it was still it still had
me on edge
you know I I was watching people like
you know a lot feel reacted you know
yeah it was fun it was like that you
know there's a lot of that and then wait
right so brain feeder for the people I
don't know yes your own label right
label yeah I started announce we have a
film company - okay congratulations
thanks man I made that with the project
you know how do they I have a company
for it so you guys put out quality [ __ ]
I always been a big fan thank you thank
you yeah so you know the movie went down
really well and uh you know some people
shifted around and you know some people
left and although my god people are
starting to leave but then they came
back you know they it was just like okay
cool and I went and did a Q&A and it was
it was full of people you know it was it
was amazing it was like the best thing I
could ask for Tim Robbins was there he
was like super excited about everything
and cuz I saw an article that sounded
spun it that was a dying that like be
straight it was hype bistros everywhere
this article was everywhere I was like
mass walkout yeah yeah you know what it
happened at a press screening you know
was like the press and Industry only
yeah allowed to go to this thing it was
like no public you know none of the fans
yeah yeah they'll be there at all so
yeah of course they walk out you know
wasn't in any way what uh but I mean
that kind of hype is great yeah I love
it you know I eat that up yeah you know
it's like I want to see why this made
people walk out yeah but you know what
that kind of thing it already it already
like the people who are curious you
should see the movie
yeah ABS people who aren't they
shouldn't it's not you know I'm saying
so it's a great divider right there yeah
yeah sure you know I used to work at the
theater when Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas first came out yeah
remember because it was Johnny Depp so
everyone wanted to see the new Johnny
Depp film right that movie got so many
complaints and lockouts when I was
working that yeah people just leave and
disgustedly what is this but it was a
great movie you know what men I know I I
knew initially that it wasn't for
everybody
yeah I knew that going into this [ __ ] I
knew it from the beginning I know it's
not for Hannibal [ __ ] I'm not knew this
man
yeah people been like that's how it
started for me in music yeah [ __ ]
terrified of me yeah that first came out
yeah like it's just the same thing over
again that was that was a challenge now
but I had to put my like it was hard to
get my friends onto that yes like I
don't understand what's going on I've
been dealing with it for a long time
yeah no absolutely I could see why you
did that we're at microvidia was
recording it we recorded it by CREB his
voice over oh great you have a great mic
his voice came out amazing thanks yeah
so anyways yes I was watching him I was
watching the clips cuz he was like
reviewing everything and it was just
funny like watch it and we'll try to
work out what's going right like this is
crazy
honestly that should have been the
[ __ ] trailer right there yeah well we
leave that we need all that
he was going crazy amen
no he was my video he was he was real
confident and super confident he was
like I know I got this I'm a voiceover
master do like eight or nine different
one now I was watching the whole time I
was watching you guys communicate
FaceTime it was really fun to see you
guys yeah yeah it was very natural
you guys were hitting it right yeah man
thank you for you know taking a chance
and getting involved with the project -
problem man yes series because you know
it's like I don't know I really I'm
gonna get all emotional now but I really
do appreciate that we can keep like you
know working together and different
different aspects and different minute
been used and finding our ways to
collaborate and [ __ ] I really value that
you know of course but speaking of which
Flying Lotus was DJ the house DJ that's
right on my Comedy Central show yeah and
you were like my my weatherman and Grand
Theft Auto yeah this keeps going way
back and like more and more so you know
good you know what's funny is uh because
I deal a with him on the road yeah and
so when he'd drop the show and then they
saw you they're like who's this fine
Louis guy why aren't you on T oh I can't
lie I've thought about that a couple of
times that I was like
my answer was like I thought about that
dog like [ __ ] man he's got to do that
with him every day no it's all good I
wasn't even mad I was happy that you
were on there I honestly like I'm like
that's a good look for both of them
you know it was I had fun doing that I
had fun yeah it was fun it's a weird
thing the thing about two years ago I
had a TV show yeah and now podcast but
yeah you seem happier though I could
tell why he wasn't having a good time
yeah like that I it wasn't my Hannibal
done like schedules that's what it is
yeah I get actually no I did well with
the schedule and I did well with having
stuff to do all the time that and that's
one thing you have a TV show and it's
yours is always some [ __ ] to do whether
it's writing whether it's editing
meeting with the writers whether is
talking to costumes yeah what this you
know casting talking to network you know
doing some promo [ __ ] it was all it was
never like it was never any time for
that couple months where I was like what
do I do like it was always some [ __ ]
needed to be done I just think yeah must
be electric though it was it was cool
and it was it was it was fun and I
learned a lot I just think the show
itself I think I went in kind of winging
it
I think trying to treat it do trying to
form a television show the way you kind
of form a stand up yeah cuz like towards
the end you like really started catching
your rhythm yeah the last yeah I think
if you had another season you wouldn't
get it yeah I gotta figure out so
I'm gonna take it I'm gonna take another
shot this year yeah that format though I
don't think it was it wasn't it was a
valley in the teleprompter thing yeah
you know and just feeling natural yeah
it wasn't but you know you had you
pitched I think the better selves
initially that's not my phone must be
your agent he's about to be a
stormtrooper in the next Star Wars so I
want to ask you specifically about your
beats your very is very very you very
like it's undeniably you when you hear a
fly little beat so it's like I make
beats are used to make beats and just
trying to try to deconstruct your
process it's like impossible I can't
figure out what you're like possible I
can't figure out like what I mean you
have to give us your mouth there ain't
no secret yes it's like I just don't I
don't always approach it linearly you
know sometimes I'll I'll start a
sequence from like you know like you
know the third bar or whatever yeah and
then sometimes it you don't you just
it's hard to explain man you know you
just it's not just a linear process yeah
I don't think about like a grid yeah
more like a sketchbook yeah that's what
it feels like when you do your drums are
you just like live drumming and then
sometimes yeah you just sometimes kind
of then sometimes it's you know it
depends on what it is yeah yeah
[Music]
no I used that was a used to be really
into making myself Bert do it that often
but when I do it you ever try to
remember when your kid you ever try to
like burp the ABC they didn't like
possibly lose a couple friends doing it
[Laughter]
gross we get done the cat they just get
here done the cat just came through
what's happening man I'm just making it
weird for everybody okay you look great
you lost all this weight hey man this is
a new man to be honest with you I mean I
have stopped drinking a lot
oh I still have my moments area now you
Rodgers you know there's a nickname I
think it's been deemed turbo Steve like
mr. Comey turbo well you do go in for
somebody that goes in Omaha you did not
give I'm like I was taking shots with
you I'm like does this ever end like I
couldn't believe how much alcohol we
consumed that that's called emotionally
scarred you were a madman oh my god
that's a start I started young with that
man I was like wrong you know like the
the the the funny dynamic about the
drinking when I joined suicidal like it
was like and here's a full beer mug okay
it was just like that was on each other
yeah it was it was pretty annoying so we
were talking about cue so cool so yeah
did you do some of the music on a little
weird in there with the soundtrack you
know the OST so you've seen it a bunch
of times
12e I've seen it in parts like that was
the first time I saw the entirety thing
was like at the Sundance a like and you
know dope you know but like I remember
the crazy thing for me would be
remembering when he started working on
it
and it was like it was the funniest [ __ ]
it was like trying to animate the one
thing it was just like oh it was just I
remember that yeah whoa and in this
movie is just like from that moment
tonight as god damn it wasn't I did too
[Music]
yeah you taught yourself to animate yeah
yeah well is that process well a
combination of just trial errors a
certain program friends yeah yeah yeah
just
I used After Effects and Photoshop but
you had a crew of people like helping
you I know you did it all solo you got
to remember you're talking to the dude
that will do it himself
that's very impressive that's I mean you
know slide Lotus ladies and gents like
it was fun for me yeah I just wanted to
learn how to do it yeah I've always
wanted to make cartoons and stuff yeah
always I've always been interested in
that and I was just I felt like I carved
out enough time to where I can disappear
for a little bit and my work on
something on my own
you know turned into self-taught
animator you never hear about that no
and it's like you can do it though David
Firth is well he you really uh he helped
out a lot and my giving me pointers and
you know leading me in the right
directions but yeah than that I was just
alone this is the question I have and
some other listeners might have as
somebody they might want to finance
their move how much did it cost
[Laughter]
cuz this is it take a sip of water
before you
I've got dry real eyes get all teary
eyes you really want to know yeah it was
a lot it was a lot more than you know I
have a nice house yeah I have a nice
house I'm really proud of it I bought it
you know it cost more than the house
[Laughter]
says more than a down payment
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was about it was about 400 I mean but
within the world of movies it's not and
it's not a lot but in the world of
individuals yeah that's a big gamble on
your dreams
yeah thanks Kendrick
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's real don't like it I mean I mean
I would imagine there's no other way to
do it you know you balls in man what
that yes you have to do that on your own
yeah yeah there's no you have to there's
no because there wouldn't be any other
way to do it I don't think you know it's
like it does take that chunk of money
but like uses I think it only would take
you having to be like you know [ __ ] it
i'ma sacrifice the [ __ ] out of yeah
that's it though that's like the only
way it would get finished either right
it's like if I had to invest like that
yeah
like at that point you have to succeed
you know that so you you you go all in
force discipline yeah yeah but it was
like it was the best learning experience
for me that's great now and now I'm able
to make another one oh yeah you already
got part to making or the second one I'm
gonna do a different thing but it's like
it's already you know it's already going
so it's it's yeah I'm in cycle
progression to to go from audio to
visual maybe no maybe yeah yeah I don't
think they mean they go hand in hand
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
shoot what track of yours do you is a
favorite of yours but it didn't connect
the way you thought what you like this
[ __ ] is rock people have deemed as a
deep oh man every song create now this
is one that I really like that I think
is underrated but it's called clay I
like it that's right yeah that's a good
thing
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I listen to your beats always feel
like I'm like come on make some good
[ __ ] [ __ ] write some [ __ ] down well
you know one of my favorite tracks when
you sent me the album on the [ __ ] bed
when you sent me that you're dead album
and I was like oh I need licensing it
from you for my comic this track that's
your intro I just call it the Hannibal
the Hannibal saw the next pressing
kiddie albums yeah and it's 40 seconds
long
yeah like it just feels like a superhero
yeah it feels like wrestling music like
real triumphant weight because it just
comes in
[Music]
[Music]
sorry that's you on there yeah that's
not the basic sound like that you guys
work so well together yeah yeah I just
say you guys were made to make music
together yes it's crazy like in the
situation like this where we're talking
about some old [ __ ] and I can like
recall every moment every drink yeah man
I'll tell you the truth man when I when
I first heard pimp a butterfly honestly
I just heard both of you guys like he
really heard him it was just like
everybody else working with him you guys
have a lot like a connected vibe oh it's
going hand-in-hand yeah and like I was
thinking about you guys wasn't that [ __ ]
like man like this is this is cool like
la got together in this cool way yeah
like one of the best hip-hop albums ever
yeah it was definitely it's dope that
you guys are all connected like that you
know yeah it was awesome good on
Kendrick too you know yeah for
recognizing it you know yeah yeah he
didn't have to go there he could have
when he could have went wrapped it all
the way out absolutely absolutely like
he's like he's like you're saying Kanye
yo y'all [ __ ] - y'all all music oh man
no not a B - I start crying I couldn't I
couldn't do that and start telling girl
my life story yeah you understand what's
going on I was working
that's too intense okay I don't even
think I could hear somebody talking on a
song while I'm smashing only I tried to
have sex our Kelly one time it was like
it was like a dig in the closet
literally talking to me and I was just
like felt like it was somebody back in
the world with me like watching what was
going on I just felt like making me just
turn this [ __ ] off is weird for me man
even like I mean I remember I lost my
virginity to create David though that
was funny yeah yeah my which Craig David
my first girlfriend it was the one it
was was the one [ __ ] his hit one the
one Hitler you know you know shout out
the Craig Dave of a [ __ ] yeah man I
cried this lost your virginity to see
this album it was this album it was on
your face was just like the context in
which it happened was the funniest [ __ ]
because it was like it was like the one
thing she had you she was like I'm you
know eccentric musician who's like the
only the only tape in there it's not
like she's gonna have chikorita or some
[ __ ] like you know amazing do you
wanna [ __ ] to like George dude like
album man most be the most esoteric sex
on the planet
yeah man way but I did I remember that
moment to you have listening in bed
[ __ ] it was just like wait a minute
this song is gonna be burning my brain
for it yeah I'm like yes after I got
past the song I was like I didn't really
listen to arm be a lot growing up you
know I was more into jazz and other
stuff and I was just I remember I had
this internal dialogue while I was
smashing like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
I was like it's like this last track was
terrible
the whole time I'm thinking she's in her
mind like this is fantastic and I'm just
like man this girl you have bad music
days it's like but then I remember that
once when the album get back to that one
song you know I was like okay it was
gonna be burned in my mind forever I was
like oh my god you know you was a virgin
yeah this is my first girlfriend just
like 15 purposely you gonna remember
this mother oh my god yeah it was just
weird
it's like vicariously Craig David
getting people laid since they're
teenagers that's that's a no well you
know you don't love to your beats no no
they don't even end up on accidentally I
can't say that hasn't happened have you
got up and changed yeah yeah excuse me
I'll be right back
turn this [ __ ] off you ever have
somebody stand up come on cuz it's just
on shuffle it is sometimes it'll be like
a been doing comedy had meetin a lot of
people over the years a lot of times
music come on I'm 5 met the person a lot
of time
oh my god I can't do it man yeah yeah
it's funny I prefer you know I prefer I
don't want to say prefer silence I do
because it makes it real awkward and
intense you know I preferred like lights
bright as hell if she gonna fart we all
gonna hear you did that you farted and I
can't move so just noted just make a
mental note you know but you know I I'm
not I'm not big on music and smashing
yeah because it's like is to a you know
like he was saying like in the middle of
middle of doing it in this some George
Duke [ __ ] come up in a different time
signature like real fast like 300 BPM
you need to start soloing and you just
like yeah it's like I don't know man
music it is sacred it's a weird thing
yeah like end up having my weird
memories too song I stuff too like yeah
yeah yeah yeah mr. tricky like you
trying to smash smashing in the real
boom I'm high thinking about this
like I couldn't like I'm thinking about
like the more you think about it it's
like the more MoMA it's like you know
and then you have a song when that's
real pretty or some [ __ ] that yeah I can
just see it right now are you like in
the middle of smash and then the real
beautiful song comes on your girl goes
oh what's that anyway that's the
soundtrack to Cannibal Holocaust yeah
it's like not you know sex conversation
well the first time I seen you before I
came out to LA like anyways it was a
Louis oh that Low End Theory was a while
ago and you were playing that night and
there's the first time I seen you
perform but it was wild because I'd
never seen anything like that before
where someone's just playing beats
mm-hmm and everyone was engaged
yeah like [ __ ] were just like
Chicago went through like an
instrumental thing to certain bands like
tortoise and pelicans show like that
like we had like our Renaissance with
instrumental music but it never it you
guys did something where people were
just totally engaged with hip hop beats
yeah which was like something shut up
never sit like there's people in there
was people in Chicago trying to do like
blowing 30 nights like where it's like
appreciate the beats beats where's the
rapper's what's going on yeah yeah yeah
go ladies and gentlemen Chicago's
amazing I always love going Chicago I
mean we went to a juke party the other
night
and they were treating it like it was
low in theory oh wow cuz we're just not
in their head like there was no foot
working nothing yeah so it's like it's a
different kind of vibe out here with
beats like people really engage mentally
I guess more than like physically does
that make sense or maybe it's just hi
man nine times out of ten
my face is comfortably stoned yeah by
the time you get too lonely you your
whole day has been like a training day
like with Denzel watching yeah yeah but
you haven't seen I mean have you ever
been to a juke Marti and [ __ ]
have nodding their heads like it's a
it's a FlyLo show I don't know man I
think it was just cuz isn't that this
region could be a do it in Chicago
people would have been heavy on each
other than it'll been at least a couple
people footwork yeah yeah footwork
because about to be thirty four [ __ ] to
do
I can't just be out here and start foot
working in somebody getting a bunch of
goddamn YouTube ad revenue why nobody
dance in here on the wall on my hair
nobody dancing in this [ __ ] they born
in oh my god that's my new [ __ ] well
that's our 34 yeah I don't think be the
energy I create a beautifui giri eight
what whatever I'm talking about you know
I'm not I'm not you got me thinking
about the Juke [ __ ] I always feel like
usually whenever young people be dancing
and [ __ ] like that it's just because
they ain't started [ __ ] yet I just I
just kind of comes money having all that
weird like moving fast and [ __ ] it's a
cultural difference started like la baby
yeah there's a crazy dance scene yet
yeah we're not really part of it yeah
it's like a novelty own thing here -
would you say grounding is now it's just
it's it's own thing I'm not really in a
song about what's going on
as far as like Chicago Juke [ __ ] yeah
it's like a novelty here specific yeah
yeah but I think yeah people actually
adopting it though - oh you are really
getting into it in the footwork and [ __ ]
out here
Oh like Chicago style yeah yeah yeah if
you really are really into a couple
drinks in you grabbing somebody it
happens we were the Sun dancing like you
know Paul our friend Peabody
yeah with no full-on Juke set in and
they always we always embrace those cats
out yeah yeah yeah at low in theory you
know tech life people whenever they come
through it's always love you know and
there's always like a you know I mean I
think that the golden general just would
be to turn up on any account that you
could you know it's like how you saying
hands loose ain't really gonna like it
too
you know sweating and smelling weird in
the club yeah but you know young kids
they be doing it and be like alright you
get it you know yes you just look at me
like okay cool and you know for them you
need them yeah get it crackin you guys
are gonna make a joke be oh yeah all
that [ __ ] so much [ __ ] you know I think
that is like a really sad thing is this
that there's you know it's just really
for us a lot of yeah you know what but I
don't I don't know like sometimes I wish
people could hear it all but at the same
time it's a saying earlier we've been
working for years yes like I remember
like you know I just found some [ __ ]
today that I hadn't heard a long time
he'd be like weird little sections and
sexy I just there's a little a little
something but it was still well I
remember going over your house a couple
years ago and saying oh they play me
something that people say isn't that you
at all
and it was his beat was silent this uh
this is a dis beat and then I just
smelled a little weed the hook hook and
verse and then back into the hook one
take yeah I smell the weed and rappin
walk
crazy now what's it called you know we
call it carbon and walk three or four
crazy yeah that'd be you crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we should do it we thought we joked
about it we've talked about it but we
should do an album man yeah I think I
gotta get a music zone the music and
that do the doesn't it doesn't have to
be just one thing you know how I imagine
it I think it can be it can be like you
know the universe yeah it could be
different you could do music you can do
skits you do all of it it can all it can
all exist as your you're a better sauce
man oh you cuz you rap too yeah he does
yeah play any instruments not really I
mean I fiddle yeah I thought you were a
white dudes like specifically what type
of white dude like I do with dreads are
like I think we met the first time in
2012 that pitchfork yeah professor oh
yeah
and so yeah just I knew the name Flying
Lotus I knew the [ __ ] beer the music
I think my the most knowledge I you know
I probably heard other stuff for not
attributed to you but I think I knew the
Adult Swim bumper beats and all of that
yeah and I knew the name and everything
I saw that Flying Lotus I think that's
for and then it's probably white dude
yeah and I was like oh
[Laughter]
Flying Lotus probably why honestly I got
people saying like oh man disappointed
you're black oh my god I'm so
disappointed I thought you were white
all this [ __ ] like I was happy with
black I'm like this looks weird this
show this video of this show this show
was one of the craziest so it was a
pitchfork after-party Oh bottom lounge
it was good
Eric Andre show live yeah that was a
great show and we had a Fonzie Matt The
Breakfast Club cats okay yeah yeah yeah
that's Fonzie Mac and kales yeah cago
yeah
and then FlyLo closed it out you click
and it was crazy and I was sweating on
just just say I was sweating profusely
it's nice so like three towels that
night I was sweating profusely and I was
very emotional and they were curious
smiling a lot occasionally gritting my
teeth a little bit inside of my cheeks
get the point you remember that [ __ ] was
a great phrase yeah I don't know if you
remember after you were just chilling by
the stage and I walked up to you and I
had just got some weed tincture I walked
out I was like hey man try this and
you're like what is this I was like it
sweet thing sure you're like cool so we
like for we yeah it's just like it's
like alcohol we looked at it you were
like bird and just frame
immediately can't believe you just do
that has some funny [ __ ] I'm confused
why it's big deal it was like in this
weird bottle it was a spray thing and
you just was like cool how many you're
like how many pumps and I was like not
three or four you not cool hey listen
ladies and gentlemen you can get me high
anyway anytime anywhere yes honestly
I've kind of chilled out on some of that
as well there's certain you could tell
you have a trusting face or something I
appreciate that
how's my hand me a joint yeah so we
gonna smoke I don't like you I just
don't want to be around people take this
the hopes of you opening up to them also
weed [ __ ] mmm you know cuz weed makes
people connect yes like sometimes it's
like what people they do that than the
autograph yeah I think I gotta find yeah
I gotta find the right the right [ __ ]
but also alcohol is see that's about to
say like the alcoholics is not a good
look
smoking so it's like ya know you know
yeah it's nothing like that especially
when you're already [ __ ] gone yes
it's not falling in the question that
comes in my mind is like like what's the
rate what's what's the massive
difference when you like extremely high
when you extremely drunk like what so
men know I feel like Emily like I always
had this I had this thing where I always
talked about the smoker always finds a
drink it was like there's always this
weird connection that happens with a
person that you know you get somebody it
does both its usual that somebody does
both with this one that they do heavier
you know I mean is like this thing we're
always one because I've never been a
smoker yeah I've had moments where I've
smoked before it is like overblown you
know that's how I felt about it but it's
like again I've always been a
heavy-handed drinker it looks like I
always have this I gave up on trying to
get him he doesn't smoke don't both of
you guys [ __ ] with DMT I mean you guys
all [ __ ] with that [ __ ] no more I mean I
think I think people get the wrong idea
my risk is we've done it doesn't mean
you do it all the time yes no it's not a
song called The Empty we've definitely
got the DMT like what was the
inspiration like was it just you went
out there and then was like man we gotta
do this interview or again start all the
way yeah that's too crazy it's too deep
huh oh yeah that's funny that you say
that because at one time because I've
never done it and I asked a friend and
he was like it's just either you he's
like there's two kinds of people he's
like the people who've done it and the
people who haven't done it that's true
and that's it yeah it's crazy you know
it's you always get like everything in
between is we're late but yeah it's not
a hype thing it's not like I'm about to
go do this DMT right yeah it's like if
people try to treat it like that is
nowhere near that guy yeah
what the [ __ ] is DMT couch these are
beyond me there was the separation it
means like the people that do it yeah
it's a whole it's like a quick what 15
minutes 15 minute high right depends
yeah but 15 20 30 somebody go and come
back you smoke it you go somewhere and
you come back now you see some [ __ ] yeah
when you go out of your body yeah yeah
from what I hear you see fractals you
see you're in another universe you're
like understand things that you didn't
use to understand like it's supposed to
be a little bit in clarity a bit yeah
yeah some someone called like a Vision
Quest yeah you know kind of like that
they give you take a 15 minute trip and
all of a sudden you come back never the
same again so I just come back I'll
leave now come back what all these bars
that I need to get to
for some people it's very do you feel
like it helped you creatively yeah both
of yeah but not like directly it's not
made me a better artist it just makes me
more curious about inside you know I'm
like what it's all what it all means and
stuff I think um as very is very
powerful yeah I I think anyone who's
curious about it should try it
yank if it's something that you know
it's oh it's very sacred you know you
don't want it's not no party [ __ ] DMT
yes
at the farm splice and you would like it
the handbook yeah yeah you should try it
maybe I should I think I would like it
too we should do yeah you guys yeah you
go on a trip yes take a little voyage
take a little journey it's worth this
work I remember like even like you know
like she do a podcast on DMT you'll be
like drooling on yourself like you're
never gone right you just go right
there's none of this let go all this
theory yeah you know just let it just
you know be very personal like it's
weird like there's patterns of the way
people talk about it and it's always the
same it's not anything to be viral you
know yeah yeah yeah it's the sacred
experience yeah yeah that's that's how I
always hear about it yeah well you're
now saying like when I remember like my
group was like specifically Christian
yeah and like even when I did it whereas
before it was like a pre notion where
like you know I didn't grow up with
drugs and stuff in the house and all
that stuff that I literally after I did
I had this moment of like well I can't
not talk about it yeah it's not
literally the first person I told about
it was my dad I was just like I
literally was like hey man this really
exists
yeah and my dad's is his reaction to it
was more of that of like wow that's
compared to like you [ __ ] up it was
just yeah Wow yeah yeah and everybody
who I've ever talked to
I told my grandmother I did it it goes a
bit further than like did your immediate
surroundings so it's like yeah like you
know what you're saying that does it
affect your creativity I mean ultimately
yeah like by way of the fact that yeah
just open some doors you're like yeah
you do you really do and you can feel
the wind and you can yeah like a very
spiritual experience absolutely yeah and
it's like you know sometimes you people
love to like downplay the idea of that
but it's like nah like don't ya don't
mistake it like yeah it's like it's
always been that ya know I mean yeah I
have friends that are big
like man you just just do it yeah
there's a lot of stuff you're gonna
untangle yourself
yeah those friends like that you know
the castle but I did the MT yesterday I
said it was all right
it'd be like drinking a Heineken
yeah wait excuse me yeah but yeah that's
just cool it's not that you guys look at
it like that like I look at there's like
a lot of you know people don't really
have the real experience you know you're
not doing it properly yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that also it's like when you do
mushrooms like you don't do mushrooms at
a [ __ ] house party while you're
smashing well also - you say oh I did
mushrooms but I only have one cap yeah
dosing right yeah but it's totally
different totally different exactly if
you have a whole eighth exactly like oh
yeah that's true that's true
you [ __ ] wig out and then everyone's
like don't [ __ ] with shrooms cuz you
crazy dudes balls in all the time -
identity though I didn't I never did a
psychedelic or anything until we did DMT
and then after that the funny thing was
the same way I would drink would be like
heavily it was like it almost like
immediately you get so you get shot so
far out like you want us you do want to
see it again you do want to like go back
into those moments but the funny thing
is it only translates like you eaten
even more mushrooms
you said you're struggling is [ __ ] it's
like I can't go where it's like you
can't the - you can't attach it to [ __ ]
man yeah that's just what is it did you
guys both get the fractals
oh you mean everybody's versus the frack
know there's more than that yeah yeah
wait goes way further than I heard that
there's fractals and then there's like
little people yeah
beings
things that you talked to this beans
beans like little alien people or some
beers right like something not being
nice but all other beings yeah it's like
you communicate with them and you
something about being very Massey and
fractally it is that accurate it's true
it's in and around there yeah we got to
do this [ __ ] HP how do you take it you
put it in your your cuticles or do you
sip it right right it's like a full-on
needle to between the toes and you kind
of [ __ ] out for it no it's rip it right
out of a bong this there's a couple of
different ways to do it right there yeah
there's a lot of ways how you do it the
way I'd recommend you guys do it is
probably like you know you probably
smoke it out of a bong yeah a little bit
of ash at the bottom of the bowl and
then put some DMT and then put some a
little bit of weed on top of that just
goes like you don't want to burn the DMT
yeah you want to have it come it's true
that's right vaporizers have a DMT party
after the show yo man don't no lie no
lie I've always we almost choked into
the bro 15 people no real real [ __ ] we
would always joke about it - he'd be
like how do you introduce people like we
get like a smoke machine and like that's
your concert and then it just it just
[ __ ] people [ __ ] up but it's like you
get in trouble doing that like is it a
connective drug if you're doing it with
someone else do you connect or is it
just a completely high school you got to
realize some people they don't play God
people ain't ready to see that [ __ ] and
also - yeah when you do it right the
experience is not like of Earth yeah no
it doesn't feel like here yeah yeah can
you see your body no I mean all of the
all of the girls when sound goes away
every there's this game called drunken
bar fight on knockdown you see your body
and you have to pick up yourself you
guys ready to make that next move you
know that makes big move maybe change
the job up maybe start some kind of a
creative endeavor get into something get
into something creative a new project
there's something something like that
but people got to see then people got a
people got to know that you you know you
got to increase your visibility you got
to let people know what you've been
working on or what you trying to do and
that's where Squarespace comes in you
got to have a website a domain all that
stuff and with Squarespace does for you
is it makes it real easy to get that
poppin get your portfolio out there let
these people know you exist make a
beautiful website in seconds or maybe
not seven minutes but you gotta have
that website you got to be a
professional for Christ's sakes and a
lot of professionals use it I can't name
any off the top of the head but I'm
telling you it's true I've heard it on
other podcasts so uh it's beautiful
there's a award-winning designer
templates it's a beautiful way to
present your ideas in an online format
of course I mean like you can just you
know there's nothing for paper so you
got to do the head it's an all-in-one
platform and there's nothing to install
you've got a patch upgrade those
annoying upgrades that give you two
options either you upgrade now what are
you doing later but they don't give you
that skip option which is [ __ ] and
they don't do that to you and the
customer service
its award-winning they've won awards for
how they help you out when you're in a
bind it offers a unique domain
experience
fully transparent and simple to set up
very simple to set up and it's flexible
for everybody you want to be creative
you want to do a blog about giraffes you
want to start a business selling venus
flytraps and crystals you just you know
want to be some kind of artist like
everybody else
everybody's a friggin artist Squarespace
so go on over squarespace.com right now
I've put in the promo code Hannibal
h8 and ni ba l Hannibal and you get 10%
off go ahead make that move you deserve
let these people know it's the most
terrifying thing ever I love it I love
it so much I could tell by Cousteau play
scary why is it scared [ __ ] to
jump out at you jump scared yeah yeah
and I was having VR mode yeah wondering
should I get into 5 500 a terabyte joint
PT I do have but get well that's the
reason I keep it one guy's PlayStation
guys yeah
yeah I tried to put it
the Xbox for life we go get them all of
the 360 I love 360 I love the Xbox but
after that [ __ ] up it may take away
too many games I bought a ps3 out of
spite when somebody stole my Xbox 360 I
was like I'm gonna get an Xbox 360 and a
PS in and I never played that [ __ ]
despite by for somebody to Sony but
Evernote for man yeah what's the market
share for both that's not I was
PlayStation more popular I mean it's
just comfort for me it's not even a
preface just I got a xbox I like I just
walk to which you yeah I wasn't really
feeling I think they both are great
systems they're great machine they did
they did I didn't really want them to
you know I really wanted to be on the
Xbox yeah but why why cuz Microsoft
think the last two were good I thought
the 360 was better than ps3 that's
personally I just I liked it yeah yeah
but it seems like they stumbled just a
little bit yeah you know effect that
they ain't got the VR joint together and
you know like just the immediate like
what you can see where it's like okay
the inner interaction on the PlayStation
you can't deny how really user friendly
that [ __ ] became yeah yeah and it's like
like going from the 360 like you saying
where you had this great thing to where
it's like you know then you have to like
redo it and then you have to like okay
they've given you a new system to
operate with it and yeah and then you're
kind of like yeah it was weird and the
exclusives became yeah like yeah anyway
yeah PlayStation just came all the good
yeah uncharted 4 was my
and that was that last of us you guys
yeah what are you emotional as game
though yes
yeah I was good almost cried yeah I was
good yeah how did you get your channel
on
Granta follow me ta yeah okay man that
was a that was dope that it's this guy
Yvonne he he's the music supervisor yeah
he's a he always like hit me up and just
be like yeah one day we're gonna work on
some [ __ ] we're gonna figure out how to
get you in one of our games are big fan
like yeah alright well you know whenever
and then they were working on GTA and
eight they asked me about some songs if
I had some songs I want to contribute
yeah I played a whole bunch of stuff
stuff me and thunder were working on and
you know all type of [ __ ] and then they
asked him like yeah so what would your
ideal scenario people
my ideal I'd have radio station you know
that's what I that'd be the best yeah
and uh you know they didn't say anything
but after a while they brought it up
they brought that up to me and I was
like absolutely yeah I was so happy to
see that yeah yeah when I was playing
that game I was like steal a car go to
fly low yeah video game just went up a
lot of notches right I did a lot of I
did a lot of cruising in a game just you
know that was I have to say that was
some of the most fun ever at that time
right there you disappeared yeah we all
did you know I felt like at at that
point in October whenever came out like
the world just disappeared for like two
weeks and play Grand Theft Auto five and
yeah
it was really dope I really love that
yeah it was a great moment in time for
but you know like when games can be
events like that yeah as a person who's
always play games I I always loved those
moments like when I was at the Arkham
night when Batman game see now that's
like Resident Evil for me right don't
feel that about every game they come up
with this yeah yeah it's safe to say
still even groundbreaking in the
technology of video game where it's like
the ability to scare the [ __ ] out of you
know yeah and it's president evil is a
linear game right yes you go through it
like in this one it's like it's not too
hard either it's not too easy to where
you like never finish it yeah yeah you
know that's cool I like when get like
Uncharted Slyke that yeah exactly you
know you get through the game but you go
through this journey yeah yeah it's too
busy - yeah linear story in and be done
yeah like those open-world like there
was that game The Witcher you're playing
some swords and all you got your armor
you got a bi [ __ ] you're gonna find
jewels my real life that's too crazy for
games all is customizing shit's like
dude I don't want to live in this world
now I get through this game last time I
got that crazy about a gang was Diablo
we did a whole tour in half or whatever
it is I play yes slowly started like
assimilating my friends or is like come
yeah yeah no it was like that my client
was like that you never would ever
expect to play Diablo and [ __ ] like that
were playing like magic card yeah you're
like that one scene in poltergeist and
the girls are staring at the screen I
actually went through the magic cards
thing yeah recently we were working on
on Hannibal show around then is when I
got back into magic the gathering of
magic no I don't know what it is yeah
and it was people when I was 7 and 8th
grade that played it I didn't like these
cards are supposed to attack [ __ ] I
can't it took me a while to get on but
when I got into it I got I got real
nerdy but then there's people like the
purists right to do the old-school [ __ ]
like yeah a new-school magic yeah and I
got some friends are real nerdy with
that stuff yeah and they're like yeah I
used old dicks that's sick man the crazy
thing is those cards never go down in
value yeah yeah that's pretty sure
hundred dollars some of the artwork some
of the artists that have come through
they have like this really like strange
training process of like picking the
artists even do it yeah so it's like
even though the art may look similar
it's like it's a new person and then
it's like it's a I mean you even have a
couple friends that work on it you know
it but it's one of those things where I
remember like seeing a car that was like
a car it could be like $100 $150 for one
car and I remember seeing that like 15
years ago when I was a kid and they were
walking into a comic store today and the
joint is like 200 I'm just like this is
insane that's crazy
dude yeah I'm like would you say this
one do you collect comic books oh man
yeah I'm uh you know I mean you know you
know you know I'm not I'm not super I'm
not like what's that dude from The
Simpsons a comic guy yeah yeah ain't got
that far but I mean I do have my moments
and if you did the funny thing is they
don't it don't come out you don't
realize you actually are that nerd until
you've lost somebody in a conversation
yeah you start going off on a tangent
about some [ __ ] and they just they're
like I didn't even bike I wasn't even
trying to get all into that and you just
like like I am a comic nerd ever getting
the comics you know at the story I used
to work at a common a little bit yeah
yeah I was like I was it's like it's
weird because it's like again you the
whole concept of collecting like you
know to get the guys that collected
baseball cards and basketball yeah oh
yeah you know and it's like it was a
good it was actually a good thing
socially because it's one of those
things were you know even somebody you
wouldn't talk to normally if you had
like two Michael Jordan's you had the
two cards or whatever yellow Neil Rookie
of the Year
yeah yeah you know and then you keep
your Beckett with you you can I was just
one of those kids like there was part of
me that was always a collector but then
Marvel me and my dad literally used to
have Marvel and DC arguments like I mean
like modern comics tattoo I turned 18 I
was like what you gonna get tatted I was
like Marvel it was one of those things
like I grew up like that my dad was kind
of he was he was he was a comic nerve
but it was like Detective Comics like I
wouldn't want to call that super nerd
because it was like you were kind of
still based in reality but me and my dad
when I was a child my dad would get
flustered because I'd be like he
couldn't tell me Batman and Superman
were like valuable like he couldn't he
couldn't just I was like you know nah I
was like I wouldn't have it then I
started working at a comic store and I
would be bagging comics and I'll be
reading them while I was bagging them
then after that you know they'd pay me
they literally would pay me a $20 store
credit and $20 a actual
- yeah this art spend all my money in
the comic store so funny there's like
some alternate universe where you worked
in the comic book do or and I worked in
the video games
I worked if I was like clerks
I worked at a Electronics Boutique oh
yeah it's crazy right yeah crazy but ya
know it's just the collective [ __ ] you
know I was always on it so it's just
like I try to pass it down to my
daughter but it's like it again and say
my clicking it's not the same dynamic
these kids don't give a [ __ ] about no
today yeah yeah it's like it's like what
I gotta read yeah cartoons does it
influence the music at all oh yeah man I
mean like literally they gave the Golden
Age of Apocalypse a his named after the
age of the pocket it was also partially
named by my mom but the Golden Age of
Apocalypse Apocalypse there's a song
called FLIR ultra mm-hmm that's a brand
of card that's a card company oh [ __ ]
they make sports and everything
but for me it was always flew over
tomorrow so it was I FLIR ultra I mean
I'm trying to think was it there's a
couple in there even the writing there's
well it seems like some of the writing
comes from being characters and yeah
absolutely man I was shocked when I
found out that Tron song was about the
intention from the beginning everybody
thought it was some girl I was madly in
love with yeah
nah just my kid and now there's a
commercial wait have you seen the
commercial it was that Purina commercial
were two dudes about to get some ass and
then like he kept his eyes with his cat
inning like low-key pushes the chick
aside like goes to feed the cat I was
like I was like hi somebody must either
have known me for a while this type of
man the man of the same cloth so you're
a cat guy you like cats you can tell you
can reason with kids yeah I'm getting
tired of seeing these rescue dogs
I'm tired of this yeah why are you tired
of seeing thumbs getting risk don't get
tired of this [ __ ] man cuz honestly is
like if you had him home with it just
got out of jail yeah I think about it
like in terms of like your actual
homeboy you get oh boy and your boy went
to jail for murder
yeah I mean you're gonna be so quick to
like have him around like yeah you know
possible things that would get him all
riled up on stuff everybody just had a
rescue dog like you can tell and there's
naturally because of course the whole
thing is they have to be rehabilitated
but the truth is even though the person
has a rescue dog that still don't mean
the dog is like socially able to land
anytime I've seen when I literally have
to stay away from the person with the
dog is the dog just don't
they're too skittish they're too scared
they're too like Hannibal so I just got
attacked by a dog Reese that's what I'm
saying [ __ ] that [ __ ] bro [ __ ] my rescue
dogs I'm not saying that you deserved it
I'm just saying I was around that dog
and I didn't get attack Tony was getting
real handsy with a little bit into the
dog's face a little bit trying to do too
you know two white people kissing face
with you doing the white people got a
little close yeah okay me no means no
Tony
[Laughter]
I'm not saying what she was trying to do
I'm just trying to he felt like he was
[Music]
like yeah man I just I don't even with
the people with the rescue dog would
have to give you like this introduction
like that's some s mo Bush I never had
to introduce somebody to the idea of my
cat like hey be careful just try and
will like you know she you know she's
feisty the cats cats are a little but
she's she's completely like adjusted to
human like it's like but there are some
mean-ass cats though yeah I mean if a
cat they get malicious cancer malicious
cats worthless if cats could be the size
of Great Danes there'd be a lot of cat
murders that Tony that's that's why we
leave those ones in the wild which is
what you're supposed to do with these
[ __ ] dogs have you ever been to South
America or like Greece and where have
you been to a city where the city is
overrun by dogs
you're like Mexico yeah we're just be
like random as wild dogs yeah yeah man I
can't this [ __ ] was in a
wheelchair I was in Chile his mother I
think it was Chile or somewhere in South
America like there this dude was in a
wheelchair and these dogs like this is a
bum yeah yeah
these dogs stopped it was like a group
of like seven eight dogs like a full-on
[ __ ] gang
these [ __ ] stop the dude in the
wheelchair like it was 1992 and whooped
his ass further no and I was just like
this all the dogs it was a group of dogs
like where you think you going I was
watching on the roof of the venue I was
at I was like look at this [ __ ] these
dogs out here stopping cars and [ __ ]
like David [ __ ]
you look just running [ __ ] yeah and I
just saw him knock this dude out this
wheelchair just whoop his ass and like
damn near knocked the wheelchair Lopez
that's like they were chewing like they
were biting at his hands and like they
didn't kill it was like it was as if to
like it's a territorial yeah it was like
this arch it was like it was like a
bitch-ass chair and they don't really
get the concept of wheelchairs yeah just
like this [ __ ] has some [ __ ] he
was rolling on RC I was distraught I was
like I will never I was like I'm sorry
man I'm still for like a person being
able to raise the dog since they're a
baby yeah I don't I'm not necessarily
partial to was a full breed like you
know we have the specific breed but if
you're gonna have a dog
have a nice [ __ ] dog like don't you
agree with you it's like don't [ __ ] it
if you got a [ __ ] family you got kids
yes without the two-year-old of a
goddamn pit board
yeah court-case pit bull that yeah no
idea what the past in the goodness of
your heart like my ass like let's be
[ __ ] real here I can't dude I can't I
could leave my cat at home for days at a
time I'll come back my cat wolf I'm not
touch to anything maybe sitting there
like Hello it's like too much other [ __ ]
what does you worry about anxiety you
gotta worry about like it's like having
it's like I haven't like it's in between
having a kid yeah like a kid or a geezer
it's just like one of the two things
like cuz like a cat will get outside and
then be cool yeah the dog gets outside
you got to worry about that he's worried
he might not be able to survive without
you you know I'm not into it you know
it's a different kind of a bomb but I
would have a dog to be honest with you I
would absolutely have a dog I just would
not rescue like Kimbo Slice from prison
I mean like I mean it's got arrested so
he arrested so but I'm like if you had
you know I just you got to really think
about some [ __ ] like like when I saw
that that [ __ ] in the rooms with the
the family with the pitbull where they
tried to put the sweater on him and he
just [ __ ] everybody up
I wish my gosh what is this it was
Christmas turn and you got [ __ ]
Popeye on you you got like some random
ass dog in your house that you like it's
the family dog and one of the kids tried
to put a damn sweater on this big ass
rehabilitated pitbull so I will YouTube
sweater pitbull yes it took everything
in me to like not laugh and like that's
what you get Scarface so here's the
question then Tony yeah if Hannibal gets
knocked out at a gig and you filmed it
are you uploading it if you got knocked
out like by random fans yeah absolutely
[Laughter]
would you about to say I would pull it
up to all my friends music music to it
[Laughter]
what's the context of me getting 9 right
was I being obnoxious I was just my
father sneak not doesn't matter I
wouldn't even if you were totally in the
wrong I wouldn't do that it's not a
privacy reasons would you would you take
time and edit it oh yeah
wait did he kill them probably Oh
I mean like it's not like a small margin
of like the dog heaven like the ability
like let me back off a little bit he's
taking whatever he bit oh yes some new
[ __ ] happening like the end of last year
I was just saying this is a news story I
don't think they have that the footage
of it yeah yeah crusty man it's like
what the hell did you think was gonna
happen today we just invited people to
just get out of prison into the house
just to hang out and [ __ ] and it's like
I don't know about that you know or he
might have been like one of them
fighting dogs and then they like he felt
like foster for yeah yeah you can't
handle a [ __ ] pit bull with issues
yeah man I like to imagine this I I grew
up with my homeboy Cameron and Taylor
graves and ever since we were kids they
always had a Doberman Pinscher yeah yeah
they're really good when they're loyal
but the funny thing is the crazy thing
is when we were kids they had this one
dog named yogi yeah yeah yogi was like
fool by the time we met them the dog was
already fully grown but it was one of
the things where it was like it was a
guard dog yeah so it's like you know in
one respect it was like okay cool you
know you guys got a guard dog you keep
in the back and you know it's a family
dog but you guys you know when you have
your friends over you know you keep the
dog in the back but then it was some
[ __ ] that like the the funny thing is
like whenever a family gets used to a
dog they kind of treat it like they try
to treat it like it's human but the
truth is the dog will still have the
tendency to try to take dominance over
the house yeah yeah so every now and
again territorial is yeah it's so so we
had example on the fact that your mail
yeah it smells everything
yeah you can feel it you can just feel
it and someone's drinking that that
she's sometimes you can't really play
well yeah some his graves like we would
come over the house and his graves that
had the dog in the house like it was
like like it was cool because it was a
family dog so he would like literally
like me my brother everybody come on see
we'd be sitting there like we'd be out
on the outside like outside the house
and like my child coming in like miss
graves quit [ __ ] around put that
big-ass dog back in the back like that's
not it's not another human that's just
chilling in the room like put that
[ __ ] in the back for you fight
one of our dicks off that beast and then
the funny [ __ ] like after that dog died
they wouldn't got another another of
Doberman and so we thought we had a
chance he got it when he was a baby so
it was all goofy you know you always
hear the stories of Dobermans being all
goofy when they kids but then is some
[ __ ] that happens that I actually saw
with my own eyes there were the purebred
Doberman yeah we were all able to pet it
we were all chillin it was cool but then
when that [ __ ] feet went from
being like this buddy was a goofy little
kid that his feet just kind of turning
in a little more yeah all this other
[ __ ] psychologically start head anyway
that's a great description yeah because
they look all weird goofy yeah big crop
was a crowd they were gonna do when he
got a while I got you guys when you see
there's a little goofy chasing [ __ ] like
yeah yeah and we were like yes we can
finally play with the dog that
[ __ ] got a little older in like
it started with hands stretched straight
and you start going like this you know
and then when I see you walk in the room
you start going like this yeah and we're
like wait a minute I hadn't been over
your house this [ __ ] dog been
seeing me in his like this slow turn
it's like a slow process of a turning
into like this prison in me dude you
know this the history of the Doberman
yeah like he was he the dog it was it
was a man with last name Doberman and he
was a he was a bill collector and
basically he bred that dog from it was a
German Shepherd Rottweiler
greyhound knows he took all these dogs
and made this super breed so like when
he went to go pick up like pick up the
checks whatever mhm
[ __ ] tried to run off or again
SiC the dog yeah yeah so he'd have two
of them all the time and he'd SiC
Doberman that's like the history of the
Dobermans I'm saying that that's what it
was bred for yeah
attack protect and chase [ __ ]
that's a dog that you've been seeing
every every couple days hey what's going
on a second and then after certain time
you like okay yeah I Cameron I'm not
really coming over to house this week
they are they that lease a big shiny
coat you know you know the real strong
muscles in this thing even to this day
one to my boy Ted let me enroll through
I always have to consider like 10 HR
house that's the dog's house Taylor
won't you come over my house like you'd
be thinking like dogs or racist because
I'm black and be like his the owner is
the dogs pick up off energy like the
lack of having black people around
reflection of the owner yes absolutely I
don't understand why you just keeps
attacking my black friends it's like
maybe watching the TV a little more you
know soul search something so yeah I
mean I would absolutely have one but I
just that's my whole you know I that was
me so llamas versus campus
I wanna I wanna put this track on cuz
this is one this is a joint uh it was
okay
Wiz Khalifa mixtape this is one of my
favorite features of yours oh yeah this
[ __ ] smooth man that's the boy right
there your honor Wiz Khalifa song and
then not a lot of people know that me it
was really cool yeah there's the track
bro this the one yes I think this is the
best track on the tape on this tape is
this in a plane on a plane well this is
one of them boys man he really is
something special
deadman shout out shout out to his plea
for the hippies yes
you know he's these cool [ __ ] man he is
how's his studio process is he was like
super bang it out prolific in a very
affectionate yeah yeah like in a very
interesting way man like he's like I
feel like there's a whole like thing
that he tapped in and into that's
specifically his experience so it's like
you know I've had a chance to be in a
studio with him when he had ideas
already going where he'd come and start
from scratch you know you know and his
process is like it's very not connected
to and from what I can see it was like
it was always very much like there'd be
an environment going on but he would
still be in this one little box inside
the bigger environment and it's like I
mean I imagine some people a lot of
artists are in like that
yeah but the way it would translate when
they will go into words was like you're
hearing him in real time just being
himself like non edited real
straightforward like like to sit like
the the get a good example was uh that
song right there yeah like he was
recording the lyrics while I was there
and playing so it's like what you're
hearing is basically like live actual
him just you know they like it's big you
know like doing the whole thing like
that and it's like like even to where
it's on my album where with the song
that we did this on my album it's like
you know you know depending on how well
you would know a me or is it like the in
the important the Jim the importance of
gin it's like you know we had this real
moment in the studio we would just be
like you know we're talking and he's
like we talked about like you know
drinking and [ __ ] we talked about all
these everything cuz he's a smoker yeah
like everybody knows we has to be the
smoke again I never I told you the
drinker in the smoker yeah so we had
this moment where we just kind of level
with each other he's like why y'all
smoke you ask me about that man you know
it's just my choice you know some one
thing I picked up on and I just stuck
with it that's the one thing and it's
like you know I can put it down I could
or whatever try something different but
I was like nah man it's drinking for me
you know and so we start talking about
it you start talking about Hennessy and
like what it does and all this stuff and
I say yeah man and then we
literally had this moment where we came
to the Jen talk where it was just like
you know tell me how nasty Jen could be
or whatever and you know you'd be like
man I don't know man I'm [ __ ] it's
like you know it's like old cats
drinking I was like you wanted there's a
reason why old cats be drinking gin yeah
I'm like you know I'm trying explain it
to him so like the only way I could
explain it to him I was like the only
way I could explain it to you is if you
actually go it go there with me so we
actually have this moment where we're
sitting here drinking cups of Bombay
like full like you know facing them yeah
they see Bob ain't no ice bombs and I'm
introduced to George it warm in in a
plastic cup that's some Thundercat ass
[ __ ] some said that it gets you fighting
magic yeah so he's sitting he's like
this is [ __ ] terrible this is
terrible this is [ __ ] and so he's
trying to smoke the counteracted I'm
like that's gonna make it worse I'm just
like man just ride it out and so he's
sitting there and as the night
progressed he was like and I was like
you see how you still here as I used to
not you're still in the room yeah he was
a yeah and I was like that's why gin is
the one and so we wrote we wrote just
the music that we wrote in that moment
is exactly what it was is like you
sitting here drinking cups of Bombay you
know it's just real [ __ ] so like Wiz you
know is it the funny thing is what
happens in the pop world rap to where
you know you like sometimes you like all
that's you know he'd be on some other
[ __ ] like you want some pop world [ __ ]
all right
but the truth is it takes a special type
of person to be able to try to run in
that lane definitely you know I gotta
give the new props because he really
like he owns it he owns like his is the
embodiment of what he's created for
himself yeah you know everything from
Mary and Amber Rose at one point in
having kids and I remember we were
writing music around at the time he was
married to her yeah so there was a lot
of music that would come up that was
about her that I don't think anybody's
gonna hear I say but I'm pretty sure he
may want to be probably then burn that
[ __ ] to the ground like you know but I
remember it I remember him being like
you know because you observe and report
as artists and that's probably some of
his best work - yes the hippie [ __ ] man
damn but we gonna keep seeing the trap
Wiz until he once he falls off he's like
check out a deep [ __ ] I wrong yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is literally in a new Batman movie
yeah black and yellow oh really
yeah I mean the commercials you see the
commercial they be I'm like is that you
know what it is like yeah I'm like did
my rocket yeah they played in the
commercial every time and I just be like
I'll be low-key in the back like couple
years ago we went to the bar with a
digital jukebox and I tried to play
black and yellow 15 just ordered a bunch
of black and yellow and it played that
[ __ ] twice it didn't let it go [ __ ]
I play my [ __ ] play my [ __ ] if I tweeted
or emailed touch-tones about that hey
touch-tones you owe me a few dollars you
need to look back I got them Pittsburgh
this weird bar is about me no 2015 2014
damn you remember the whole [ __ ] you say
specific details with confidence people
believe you oh yeah dive bar bout eight
people there it was a dude he's about in
his forty years the girl over there she
added a blue dress it was some people
they have weird each other those people
over here obviously on a tender day they
had no vibe gone to the bathroom
bathroom line was long because it was
like only one of them was open though
you just say sitting there people like
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
stand up she never whizzes the boy maybe
yes
what's the first track y'all worked on
together
Cosmo grandma yeah we worked on someone
Cosmo crema yeah it was okay I was only
action that is my joint that video took
them so though it wasn't no it was the
see that's the others it's a separation
outfit I keep forgetting as a separation
there's like there's a track that comes
after zodiac [ __ ] right and it's like
literally like but it still it is
separate it's like yeah it was like
right we had this moment I was like I
always compared to that scene in Nacho
Libre where uh where again is I remember
I was seen in in Nacho Libre we're not
showing eschol Ito meet and they like
shake hands and it was like they watched
that movie real drunk I'll tell you it
was that moment and we just was like
okay let's go yeah so you said you said
just track from zodiac [ __ ] flows into
the next room
[Music]
soon as I heard that [ __ ] just come in I
was like I need to work on my screenplay
[Laughter]
you do definitely your drums have like a
tribally vibe
yeah it connects to like this inner kind
of primal so oh you're very very
specific person because I somebody we
had a conversation last year somebody
that reps a huge huge star reached out
and they were like yo can you reach out
to fly low do a remix should I reach out
and ask them I don't know what you don't
say
but I'll reach out and I said anything
you like no not really worth a lot of
money can I hope they didn't you know I
didn't talk to me they just asked if you
know and I get up a tree not gonna know
who it is I can wait say it and then
edit it out
it'll be worse people reached out I was
thinking probably not but then I was
kind of the weirdest part is this is my
right after the roast like he didn't
even take it seriously like I forgot
what's one they wanted you to read but I
like some of the stuff he's put out I
think this is a year later after the
roast of some know that roast made him
acceptable again guys made Justin Bieber
finest jokes bro living [ __ ] out of that
it was overnight it seemed like it was
all good it was a celebrity spankin yeah
he started making he also started making
songs they were palatable for adults
yeah where he was human making [ __ ] but
they weren't playing that baby they were
playing that [ __ ] in the club yeah but
then that that where are you now with
the skrillex and diplo that [ __ ] banks
that's a hard ass be right there yeah
but that was that where are you now just
a solid it's like a undeniable song yeah
the Somali beat me out of a Grammy now
some [ __ ] I mean I think that's kind
of admirable that Justin Bieber's got
his ear to the radar or he's on he knows
the radar and he's but I hope he would I
[ __ ] with fly low you know that's a
local flight we've been tired of he him
yeah yeah yeah oh my super easy to get
yeah yeah just do me yes
like that yeah that that make it way
different from me cuz then it's like
I've been in a lot of situations where
it's like somebody who's like affiliated
with this artist yeah who was like
really close in the studio with this
person
yeah thinks that would be a great idea
if I came through to meet this artist
yeah not really heard of me before yeah
yeah and it's always like it's always
awkward yeah exactly and it's like
sometimes the idea sounds better than
the result yeah you know and let's just
connect as humans right honestly I'd
rather that just unlike that's admirable
well done man the musical is just be
better yeah yeah we actually I'm saying
at the end of the day it's about the
quality is gonna be better if you just
connect and you know I'm unfortunately
like way more precious with music than I
should be
yeah but I just like I really care about
not working and stuff that's how you
gotta be well you know so like in the
time that it'll take to make things as
well yeah it's like so I'd rather just
work with people who are like yeah oh
you're also in a place where your name
is big enough to where you could you
don't need these [ __ ] boosts like you
can do your thing and people respect you
and people are gonna be looking for you
you know like you don't like if you were
in like a situation where you're a
torrent and sleeping on couches isn't
sure absolutely you can't turn when you
try to keep the integrity of the music
as strong as possible
absolutely you know you don't start
making music when you a kid or getting
into it because it's like a million
dollars you get into it cuz you love it
some people do though and that's the
[ __ ] you can seem to learn you can see
people got their own reasons for doing
it you know and every every reason is
okay yeah yeah but my you can hear it
immediately can you can hear the
difference yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I knew it was my turn to talk with
sometimes I just like to let it sit
sometimes you know on the radio you got
a [ __ ] crazy tour coming up like that
[ __ ] you're doing and it's a run what is
it is Tel Aviv only that's happening I
bought a bulletproof vest just bought a
bulletproof vests they canceled my god
have you gotten to Tel Aviv is sold out
already yeah yeah yeah yeah have you
gotten any contact about it where they
said don't perform no it's just the
climate of the world is different man
yeah and like I mean it's not I don't
when we come back yeah I'm dude I'm
literally like man the weight it's not
about living in fear it's about just
being smart and it's like it's one of
those things were like you know it's not
not not steaming one specific place or
anything like that but like the moments
that you have that are really like when
you when the more you travel the smaller
the world is you know I mean it's like
you be right next door while she be
going down
oh man I would have never thought it
he'd be like well you were there I was
down the street from the first [ __ ] yeah
we were going out that night to go try
to meet up with cats to go on a tour of
just going around going to people's
shows and [ __ ] cuz it was like it was
right before I was I was doing I was
being a participant in the Red Bull
Music Academy yeah and you know we bout
to go out and at night we seen people
running this way and I'm just like this
hey anybody ever had a reason to run in
Paris so it's just like we sitting here
and then the girl goes on social media
in this like oh man they were here but
they like they shooting and like no
[ __ ] way you know like you're there
you know and then the six degrees of
separation thing like one of my friends
is like the guy run in the front of
house at the [ __ ] and you just be like
this you know so you know I don't scare
me but it's one of those things where
it's like yeah I mean I got
this long tour and I just the the
climate like I said for America and
abroad right now it's just really
volatile I think so it'd just be smart
to have something that seems to make
sense to go with it right you know but
yeah I'm a super juiced about this tour
like I've always I've always been like
I've toured my whole basically my whole
adult life and you know to a child parts
of my part of my childhood but yeah this
is like a really long tour and it's
getting attitude who's rolling out with
you it's just uh so far I mean I'm still
trying to figure it out right now as far
as I open there but you know and what it
could possibly be but this just mean the
same cats my trio you know play some
[ __ ] different you know different dress
different you know feel different think
different force ourselves and the
difference [ __ ] that's the one thing I
love about touring and playing because
it's like you exasperate ideas and you
get you're forced to change along with
the part where the playing level goes up
and everybody starts almost speaking
telepathically onstage like I almost had
half a mind to try to record this next
like by the end of the tour just to
record just to see I heard the single
the single smoke this [ __ ] would have
Michael and Kenny yeah yeah some some
more them dudes man it's like yeah man
that song with the name of the album is
drunk yeah that photo yeah what the you
coming above the water you know it has
so many different meanings you know yeah
you know there's the part where like
even more even talked about the drinking
where if you know me as I of course I've
been a drinker for a long time you know
doesn't mean I plan on completely late
crashing the plane into the into the
record like and he went out in flames
like it's not doesn't mean that's got to
happen but it's one of those things
where it's like you know it's it's a bit
of a will another or like a observe and
report kind of thing you know it's like
the how things have really been you know
you know without you know a Lego saying
well I think I said maybe a while ago
maybe in conversation that we had where
I like
learned from him to be honest about your
music you know so it's like this being
like that moment so it's like it's
really interesting because and this also
so happening to be the longest tour I've
ever been on by myself yeah I've always
told with other people like that tour
with Erika for months
suicidal that's just about as long this
is probably the longest stint that I've
got on this tour mm-hmm something like
two and a half because I go to Japan for
like a couple weeks yeah yeah it's going
and it's like it's it's as it's being
added on to so it's in Japan like
straight show yeah well no I'm gonna
take some time off I like it you try to
get somebody pregnant you know think got
you you know do some weird [ __ ] by a
bunch of weird toys and [ __ ] you know
what sure cuz you didn't a lot of
European cities and Israel and Turkey
wasn't the wow this spot out the way
you've gone over there oh [ __ ] these let
me turn it up get it Oh decided to be
here I wish I could stay two more days
Ireland right the sugar Club I think
certainly yeah Ireland Dublin I forget
there's this club called the sugar club
I think it's in Ireland yeah and every
time I've ever gone out there these
[ __ ] beyond a hundred yeah and
it's not I heard that too like the Irish
just getting late they get [ __ ] poppin
yeah they like get me drunk before this
[ __ ] start yeah sorry to get
stereotypical I mean [ __ ] this it's the
real [ __ ] I hear that all the time
they're very excited about music yeah
you know like just get lit as [ __ ] yeah
and it's like I mean everybody the chief
like cuz the truth is everybody does get
lit but it's like also the energy they
bring to your show yeah like he's just
saying like in so far where I've been
I won't even halfway be able to sing my
own lyrics they'd be out there like
singing the [ __ ] all loud and [ __ ]
that's dope yeah and you could feel like
they're with you as compared to like oh
they're just sitting here enjoying the
show you know you may see somebody in
the back making out you know some other
[ __ ] you know talking all through your
[ __ ] - you're trying to talk in between
and it just be like never mind
hey cuz everybody's just but they
literally they will know your music and
they will
you had different kind of a like well
we're in Australia I felt like the
Australian crowds reacted to Hannibal
differently more appreciative way I felt
like yeah we my imagine than that but I
felt like because they're witty ask
people over there man yeah yeah super
witty it on being witty they're also
kind of cheeky they like to try to like
make it seem like they got jokes dude
yeah yeah yeah but we ain't telling code
jokes like the shows are great I mean
like they were very appreciative Wow
well yeah yeah almost like on some I
don't know when he's gonna come back so
we got to enjoy this yeah yeah they do
preciate folks coming all the way over
yeah he's probably taking a pay cut far
away from the family and make it a
sacrifice I used to be four convicts we
have this weird connection like
Americans we have this weird connection
with Australians yeah it's weird
connection with them I do III but I do
have my moments where I get like you
know I get I wanna say tired of
Australia babies if you'd be having
these moments every night again you may
meet that one Australian dude yeah oh
yeah he always got some [ __ ] for you
you'd be like you'd be talking about
some Jordans you fight you could be
talking about anything he always gonna
try to trump you yeah and try to be like
you might oh man I just got through
seeing Dave Chappelle to somebody laughs
I got to come here
Oh mate I got it I got a friend that's a
good friend Z but I didn't ask you what
you know it comes out every now and
again and I know you're Australian as we
know what I'm talking about where is
this yeah you can't have nothing I mean
I just found these Chuck's out here on
the thing oh I mean I can tell you a
place to get to some chucks you want
some real technical hmm look man I
wasn't this was not as a matter of fact
conversation this was a
and I tested I tested the theory one
time I see if it existed like you know
the whole you know the crocodile that's
not a knife this is a knife that's not a
beer it's like I tested it I just made
some [ __ ] up I was like man I don't even
remember what it was but I just made
some [ __ ] up I was like oh man I got
this crazy you know it's got this crazy
jacket yeah and the dude was just like
and I said it immediately after I said
something else that was like denoting to
some [ __ ] he bit he bit onto it and I
was like see that's that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know call out a jacket but
it's beautiful I love Australia - yeah
they got some beautiful people out there
and it's just nothing that makes up for
like it took a lot for me and Hannibal
to leave man we want you should stick
around man like it's rich - most
definitely
yeah well that's that's the desk that's
where the casino and [ __ ] is - yeah yeah
and ask - that's the city I just like a
real it feels like a real ass city like
people are real as [ __ ] over there I was
like San Francisco yeah I like - I like
the Gold Coast and like Coolangatta like
the more of the beach earhart Brisbane
yeah I like this it because you get you
get different people every suitable yeah
gorgeous part this gorgeous yeah yeah
that was a good time yeah they don't
[ __ ] with craps in the casino out there
they [ __ ] with it but it's like why it's
just not as popular they have craps
tables but you gotta like go to the
basement it's like some for real see the
crown casino I think is calling
Melbourne you have to isn't that CD it's
just like that when an American general
American casino you walk in you can get
a craps table right away you go to spot
in Vegas it's a pit with 12 craps table
musics yeah there this [ __ ] is like
really yeah you got a so you're by
yourself where that it was there anyone
else there's a couple other people but
the energy was just cuz that's a part of
it too isn't it
just trying to win money legit but if
they it gets dared on even even the
dealers would kind of just take yeah
charismatic dealers that certain spot so
you go to the Harrah's in New Orleans
you go to spots in Vegas where they get
into it
six people have little catchy [ __ ]
Australia was always I've always been
I've always been a roulette guide man
yeah I mean it's like a roulette outside
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because
there's so many ways to bet on this if
you okay what's the odds of you if you
bet on the number uh-huh hit that number
oh man what's the odds on that yeah damn
yeah I've seen I've seen some freaky
[ __ ] lottery [ __ ] I saw this my dad says
I was like a highlight reel plane in my
mind of this [ __ ] because of the
roulette [ __ ] this dude walked up and
was walking by yeah a stack of hundreds
yeah
and hit put it on double zero yeah I
almost fainted I was like I was like you
cannot so this [ __ ] came up on
like 32 I was just like this is insane
what's the eyes roulette with the casino
it's like they get it's like 51 percent
versus 49 or what you mean the house
edge yeah yeah I don't know the exact
but they got a house is that big a house
edge it is okay I just wanted a bigger
houses houses a casino craps because I
remember as long as houses perhaps the
odds bet when you have your pass line
bet and you put odds behind that that's
the lowest casino edge mmm it's putting
odds down that's the best bet in the
house how much Saudis say Oh hmm I'm
just parody Wow yeah you know spends a
lot of time in casinos hey I appreciate
that
I have appreciation sir yes sir yes sir
you got to do it every once just every
once in a while you know yeah I don't
never been to Vegas no man we got to do
it we got to do it right now Vegas
offers I've never I've never been really
awesome
we got really you were hearing is right
now I know I went as a kid or what
laughs I couldn't do anything you know
unsolicited offer the flyer I got my hat
but it was like you know for some that
you know probably wouldn't make it very
hey Vegas is very polarizing yeah
they're really gonna love it are you
really gonna hate it it took a few times
yeah I love Vegas the first like two
times I was there I was like I [ __ ]
hate this place yeah it takes a few
times yeah it takes for me it took a
couple of times so you get the spirit
okay it's so like you know don't take it
so at the surface when you go try to
enjoy it oh it's not [ __ ] you just and
you got to go you got to go have the
right experience yeah exactly
cause you have a guide or if you have
somebody out there and you know like
that helps a lot but when I was first
there I didn't know [ __ ] I was out there
I fly in for the show yeah yeah
and I'm looking around everything looks
plastic lit up I'm just like [ __ ] this
place I'm like this is like Disney World
to me I ain't [ __ ] with this place
yeah yeah but as you get to know it you
get the cultural even more basically
means that when you get to drinking I
just don't like the construction of it
the yeah the place the strip and getting
from place to place if it was just I
like Downtown Vegas just the way I've
never seen old Vegas before yeah that
was my first time you know there's like
new old Vegas yeah yeah and old Vegas is
what you see in the movies and [ __ ]
yeah yeah but like my first two
experiences of Vegas is the new Vegas
sprawled out big ass human in fact or
you do a gig you should do downtown yeah
do downtown Vegas don't I get the real
experience old-school [ __ ]
so one thing the best fact I have the
best fact I learned about casinos and
[ __ ] was it came from the moment I
remember I was in Vegas and you go you
go in you go on a casino and you be
chillin and then you look up and then
you've been in there for like two days
right cuz I ain't no windows and [ __ ]
and they keep bringing you free drinks
yeah and you'd be like this [ __ ] is
tight you don't know what's going on you
didn't go on up you didn't go on down
even I'm up I'm losing you like sucking
more money out and then you'd be like do
you like somebody have to tell you man
maybe you should just leave Manny Blake
how long has it been you bab-oh long
that's the plan and then isn't this true
I don't know Hannibal you should know
this right it's just true that they pump
games full of oxygen yes to do like it
affects you sir sure absolutely like
yeah they're like super oxygen they
they're also like a high so don't they
allow you to smoke in there yes yeah I'm
saying this is great I just walk around
[Laughter]
your place a couple times fly low and
you get incredible amount of
entertainment [ __ ] you got video game
systems yeah arcade set like lots of
DVDs full seasons of stuff so you
obviously arcades arcade arcade game
would about okay like your joint yeah
okay you guys got the same machine no
it's not the same one but same in spirit
okay just tell you what's the long as
you gone without leaving the house
that's a good question
because you could can't like that you
can probably like two and a half months
it was what I was working on kuso was
like real close by you know me and post
mates happen so yes so you're a prisoner
to your [ __ ] mind
yeah around like you know like a
november/december yeah kind of thing
yeah yeah there wasn't that like kind of
slow time yeah yeah yeah pretty much
didn't leave for a while
I mean you haven't guessed and people
come yeah cuz if you had no human
contact then you'd start losing yeah
yeah yeah that's what Cousteau comes
from I always think about that like I
just I just moved into a new spot myself
as like you know I went last year was
really intense and now I wind up in his
dope-ass but yeah and I find I've never
been able to relate because you don't
say anytime I I would be at home I feel
like I got to go out you know yeah with
it we all we were just joking about the
city like here now you got some cool
[ __ ] you don't want to go anywhere I'm
like I don't go anywhere man I got a
Batmobile in sit crevice flies [ __ ] why
go anywhere else happen to him because
he's always been tied to like go
everywhere else his house but now his
house yeah you're Thundercat you're
finally party's at you
know why there's been a couple nights
ride this would be like when I first
moved in and I was like sitting there
and I was tripping because you know they
usually have guests over whatever and
usually somebody would like be like oh
man you know I guess I'm gonna cut out
right now some [ __ ] I looked up and it's
like three four five o'clock in the
morning yeah and I was like man are
y'all gonna [ __ ] leave and it was
like and then I realized all my points
by this kind of dope yeah [ __ ] zone
would leave I was like this is cool I
still get into fights with my ex about
that [ __ ] cuz her place was tidy and my
place is dope yeah everything there
[Laughter]
swinging a lightsaber and [ __ ] big ass
team my mom my mom came over it was like
she wouldn't stop saying this I have
never seen a TV is clear I was like I
know I feel the same way my house like
this is another level I want to
apologize at the episode that was that
with you honest was that your solo
episode I think so i mean i rewatch
students assad Thundercats face insane
bunch of people tweeted it to me like
don't ever touch that man's bass
[Laughter]
look how angry that was like totally
involuntary you make if somebody was
throw punching you like when I saw it
back I was just like oh [ __ ] I'm you
realize like it was such a stage and
there's any kind of musical instruments
around it and there's a lull in a set
he'll just start playing I could show
you a couple things on bass man whenever
you ready man but yeah that's it I don't
know man I just it's that's that was
some funny-ass [ __ ] I like I like
moments in life where you like they're
candid like that because it was like I
didn't even I'm telling you it was like
I don't know it was like an internal
dialogue if you haven't you know it's
like it was like some [ __ ] that was like
the Wonder Years like my reaction did
not line up with whatever I was thinking
that it was just like just reflex yeah
it was a reflex
but you know that [ __ ] was comedy man I
you know that [ __ ] definitely got played
a lot that's like it was nice to see
like oh I do react to [ __ ]
you know it's completely understandable
man yeah completely understandable
hey man this was fun this was great hell
yeah yeah yeah thanks thanks for coming
to you guys it's good to see you all
yeah oh yeah at new album coming soon
what's wrong - was that February 24 24
call drunk it's called rock album 24
yeah getting your feelings yeah features
from oh oh [ __ ] kids Clinton oh [ __ ]
Pharrell Pharrell is on there too Mac
Miller nice and just some other [ __ ]
man's like okay yes this is your this is
I feel like this might be out your
breakout joint yeah I do wonder what
songs people are gonna take to you
because I have I do have my favorites
and the moments that are like really
like you know like a picture book where
I can remember what happened with but
there's a part where I do wonder what
part people are gonna really pick up
from it yeah so I don't want to say that
what's your favorite from the album the
album yeah okay there's a there's a
couple you see here there's this certain
songs were just like in real life in
real time it's just it's as real as [ __ ]
as they could get it's like the one with
Mia Wiz is hilarious you know because
like we have in this real moment you
know me and Wiz and uh I want to say the
title song the title song yeah you know
because it's like it's a it's a bit of a
ironic thing to it you know because it's
like it's the more one of the more up
it's actually a little bit more up tempo
without beat on a drunk your [ __ ] and
it's like it makes you want to dance but
it's like in real life what I'm saying
is just like helpful yeah it's this is
the act of being drunk yeah you know but
um yeah just to name a couple you know
look the Michael link anyone you know I
remember while we were working on that
[ __ ] it was just like we kept like doing
like hands like brothers it is lit
transform the bit yeah yeah it started
it went through a lot of phases and then
that when it finally like revealed
itself like what the song is great I
want to tell you something you know that
song okay so your saw are you coming to
the show tonight oh [ __ ] there's a show
tonight yeah of course you guys don't
nobody got no love for the West Coast
music like music and videos and like
[ __ ] together to be like me and him will
like sit together and like see clips
that we like yeah yeah music so one of
the clips I've been [ __ ] with is them
changes and you no malice in the palace
you know with that you remember that
three stooges no no no there was like
this fight in like NBA history man that
bit the footage of that fight is so
[ __ ] funny like you see the dude just
take the fines like [ __ ] imma just get
fine for this [ __ ] and just start firing
on the fans like playing that in every
city oh my god
six my god with your [ __ ] underneath
what are you doing this
what are you do these people
psychologically it's amazing I've never
seen it it's funny I didn't Wow yeah
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna end
it out but we got a you know I haven't
heard that my we'll hit album please
what song should we edit into this to
end it off so friend zone friend zone as
friends everybody check out friend zone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks thanks again for tuning in to
the handsome Rambler just wanted to give
a quick shout-out to my peoples over
there and folks right they hooked us up
with some gear and we actually record
you